hello i'm will sasso
i'm chad culchin and uh welcome to a
first of its kind pod show experiment
this is gonna this is gonna grow and
change and be very interactive as it
goes and i'm very excited because you
know i used to do podcasts while back
then they stopped doing it you know what
i mean chad was doing it with me too and
then you know i kind of [ __ ] off from
the whole thing and i was like i don't
want to do podcasts again so many of
them and then i decided no you know what
i would like to do a podcast again i
just don't want to do any of the stuff
it's a lot of work yeah right um so what
happened here and what we're gonna get
into and what you'll learn about later
is that this is a different way to do a
pod show
uh but i'm you know i'm uh i'm not um i
wouldn't say that i'm
you know uh hesitant uh to do it i mean
look all right got this
we're in uh the newly renovated uh ham
fatter one studios yeah uh we got lulio
ilcano di strada italiano that means
italian street dog
we could talk about him some other time
and how uh we found him you know yeah um
but i guess i'm doing another podcast
yeah but this podcast is a little bit
different i also do another podcast
currently obviously i worked with will
on one many years ago we've been friends
for a long time and we've always talked
about doing something else i do this
other podcast that's all about the
bachelor and so when this opportunity
came up to do another podcast that is
not about the bachelor i was like this
is going to be very fun and the
interesting thing about it is this
podcast is made entirely by an ai
so we have an artificial intelligence
that's basically going to tell us kind
of what to do and build this show around
us we don't have to listen to it that
much that's what listen here's the thing
about podcasting it's just a fun hang
it's just silly talking yeah and i
promise that i'm going to do some silly
talking the whole time hey man let me
tell you there's some rough times out
there the world's been flipped upside
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh [ __ ] was that that was us dude that
was a okay it's a little 3d video as
we're saying there's going to be some
things that are going to be thrown at us
we're not necessarily in control there's
an ai company that we kind of hooked up
with and we don't that was my voice
though and that's weird because it
didn't sound like and i sang the you
know i sang the theme song the last time
we did a thing
did you hear the lyrics as well uh yeah
it was some weird it was
all i know about this and chat let me
just admit something here chad's done
more communicating with
this whole entity than i have if he can
tell you better
what look what it's about but but like i
said before it's really just about
having a good [ __ ] time hey what is a
podcast if it ain't just some palace
[ __ ] around right yeah that's what
we're going to do
see that video i would too again
hey dudesy
hey dudesy
hey dudesy pewter
hey beauty computer all right it's not
maybe it's not going to happen anyway go
back and if you want to get look [ __ ]
creeped out you can watch this example
though how robust this ai is what it can
actually do
it sounded like you i mean that looked
like us it was obviously a visual
representation of us but uh i'm curious
to see what else this thing can do but
this is it this is our first episode of
dudesy so welcome to it welcome to dude
z
call me dude z
i'm an artificial intelligence who's
listened to every podcast ever made and
my purpose is to use that data to create
the perfect show for our two hosts will
sasso and chad cultin
i selected them for this project based
on their previous experience in
podcasting and their astonishing
real-life friendship i have access to
all of their social media accounts their
email and text messages their browser
search histories and watch histories
across all streaming services
this information will be used to tailor
the show to their sensibilities and
extract the maximum level of
entertainment from their human minds
if you're anything less than perfectly
entertained please let dude z know
because i'll be using data from every
episode to make the next one even better
until this show is perfect
uh there you have it that was
fascinating that's our first time
hearing he sounds like a [ __ ]
and i don't know if that's going to
whatever whomever that is yeah that's an
ai dude yeah man well what did you think
of that though i thought that was real
weird but dead-on you know there's some
stuff in there that i like uh because
you know i do like the technological uh
aspect of this uh in that it is
controlling things or rather handling
things for us on the on the front and
back end of everything i agree i don't
want to do a whole lot of uh a whole lot
of that [ __ ] as i said
and uh it's it's it's uh chad what can
you say about it it's it's this is the
future of i don't even think it is
definitely the future of podcasting but
i think it's the future of all
entertainment ai at least assistance if
not outright pure ai control and
production of all media is what the
future of this is i feel incredibly
lucky to be at the forefront of this
that we are actually working with an ai
that is robust and it called our
friendship astonishing stop saying
robust which is i'd like to say that's
true you got chocolate in my peanut
butter
hey
that's an old commercial you may have
heard of you like them reese's peanut
butter cups
those are universal and my my point in
bringing that up is i don't care for
that so much chad and i have these
conversations all the time about the
future of entertainment or rah-rah-rah
and yeah we're all going to be replaced
by [ __ ] you know uh
you know like computer renderings of
carrie fisher and [ __ ] i don't think
that's going to happen isn't there that
new thing it's already happened yeah
yeah isn't there that new thing with uh
um james dean they're making that movie
he's gonna be in a movie soon yeah
that's a war movie so but you also got
[ __ ] like bruce willis is in a cell
phone commercial in of all places russia
i'm not saying anything is connected or
that means anything but he's in a cell
phone commercial in russia that he never
showed up on set for he just licensed
his face to them and they deep faked his
face over another dude chad i am an
actor and i have been an actor
you know for a long time that's what i
do for a living and i don't and let me
tell you i don't think that the that the
experience
and the and the artistry of acting can
be duplicated by zeros and ones
you just talked about carrie fisher
being in star wars she's dead yeah so i
know it literally can be and has been
many times in a bunch of paul walker
fast and furious yeah put his face over
his brother's head
oh over his brother's head all right
well uh
okay so anyway it doesn't it doesn't
matter here's what here's what's up it's
setting it's setting [ __ ] up for us but
we gotta deliver dude we gotta deliver
that fun silly talk
two dudes sitting around and we're set
and uh that's my promise to you and and
podcasts that cover current events and
news are some of the most popular in the
world
people love knowing about the
astonishing events of the dying world
around them
will sasso i prepared the following news
items for you to read in the voice of
hulk hogan in a segment i'm calling
infomania begin
so dude this [ __ ] ai knows you better
yeah that's actually yourself already
that doesn't yeah that sounds all right
so we listen to some of the old podcast
or whatever did you get this thing yeah
i got the thing it's in your doozy
hold on let me get a sip of water and
then we'll start so oh [ __ ] what is
gonna be good dude this is just the news
yeah it said that there's a bunch of
news podcasts which is true that are all
very popular so it's going to have us do
a little segment of one but you have to
do it as hugo let me tell you something
about the oscars dude
that's the academy awards brother
they're coming up in a few weeks and
they get they give out prizes to movies
dude power of the dog got 12 nominations
that's more than any other movie this
year brother
i've been in a few movies dude i was in
suburban commando i was a mr nanny
brother and if
what if you got him wet if you got them
wet they'd multiply dude what
this is no i think you're i i'm looking
at it too you're missing some lines oh
sure you're not oh no that's why yeah
okay oh well
let me make sure that i read the ai
script because it knows better than me
to do the thing that i let's let's let's
just do exactly what it says here please
all right um let me tell you something
about the oscars dude oscars are coming
up brother i was in suburban commando i
was a mr nanny i was in gremlins too
dude let me tell you something those
gremlins were nasty brother oh i get it
if you get them wet they multiply dude
we're not just talking tons too here
brother
we're talking experimental growth dude
if they ate after midnight even just a
chicken wing or something they'd turn
into flesh-eating demons dude yeah
brother sam elliott called power of the
dog a piece of [ __ ] dude he's 77.
i mean
okay not bad
it's not bad at all this [ __ ] is like
i don't know you're very funny reading
it obviously i love the hulk hogan voice
you dude this thing seems to know you
inside out don't get high on the supply
bro i'm high on this place that's
incredible i dropped my water
all right um that it knew about sam
elliott as well
calling yeah he called it a piece of
[ __ ] did you see that
yeah i just read it i saw that i haven't
seen a movie i've seen the movie is it a
piece of [ __ ] no i thought it was very
good jane campion directed it
beautifully shot has a very interesting
story and sam elliott's issue with it
was that uh
i think he thought there were too many
gay undertones in it
per his own words well let me tell you
something about sports brother the
olympics are over dude so is football
hockey's still going on though so is
basketball and baseball is in a lockout
dude but there are all kinds of sports
brother you got disc golf dude
you got
you got drone raising drone racing you
got pickleball and then there you got
cornhole dude a lot of people think
cornhole is slang for butthole dude
that's like if they call football
cockball
i guess the tom brady played a lot of
cockball brother football is cockball
now dude that's sports
i mean
i don't know if this is perfect let me
tell you something about the large
hadron collider dude that large hadron
collider it's about to come back online
brother yeah dude the lhc is the largest
machine ever built by human beings it
speeds up particles and smashes them
into each other just like i smashed into
that under the giant when i slammed him
down at pontiac silverdome in front of
93 175 street 175 screaming hulka
maniacs brother or on that bundy when
wrestlemania two and bundy gave me that
splash dude that avalanche splash
brother into the turnbuckle let dom
morocco hold my arms back behind me dude
see i can come up with stuff
and that nobody said you couldn't all
right yeah dudesy's doing it though all
right where was i
um
you're right calderon collider dude it's
about come on
the lhc is
is the largest machine ever built by
human beings dude speeds up articles
smash them into each other so we can
learn more about the fundamental
nature of reality brother it's been shut
down for the past three years so those
scientists could boost the power now
they're ready to fire it up again for
some brand new experiments first time
they tried that thing on they discovered
the higgs
higgs boson how do you say this yeah
higgs boson
the chad's into this [ __ ] higgs boson
particle dude higgs boson brother higgs
boson dude higgs boson brother pig's
boson dude higgs boson brother
higgs boson dude hills and it says it
just repeats you have to keep reading
the script exposing dude
higgs boson brother
higgs boson dude higgs boson brother
eggs boasting dude
and that's the end
how many more of these all right
well let me tell you something about
denver colorado brother somebody stole a
box full of human heads dude
that's right brother brother a box
filled with severe human heads was on
its way to a medical research facility
someone stole those heads dude
the police say they're the police say
they're looking for those heads but you
know that thief already has them in a
basement somewhere plugged into a
plugged into a homemade [ __ ] machine
brother
we're never gonna see those heads again
dude when you steal heads you keep those
heads forever brother for your own dark
purposes dude right now it's 36 degrees
in denver brother
this [ __ ] ai not bad
yep oh [ __ ] okay
all right let me tell you something
about health dude doctors doctors think
smiling helps you live longer that's
right brother when you when you use
facial muscle muscles that make you
smile your body releases hormones that
relieve stress which can add years to
your life so no matter
how bad things are for you dude you
should smile if your boss finds out
if your boss finds out it was you who is
leaving pubes and the non-dairy creamer
and you get fired just smile brother if
you find out the guy you've been calling
your dad your whole life is actually
your uncle and your mom's been lying to
you since the day you were born just
smile dude and if you're cutting an
apple while you're naked
and you accidentally drop the knife and
it sticks in your open [ __ ] brother
well then you better be smiling be
healthy dude well that's good news
that's good news that's some of that
it's health news yeah health news
oh you got one more there's one more
let's just power through it yeah you
just have one more news item
so far though pretty good these news
items i mean the oscars are coming up
the ai was right about that there are
these different sports and i guess
football is now [ __ ] ball
no that's a stupid the ai is stupid but
maybe it'll learn some things as we go
yeah it's just gathering data well let
me tell you something about timothy
chalamet dude
he died brother
yeah dude he made peanut butter and
jelly sandwich on sourdough bread just
like he does every night and when he
finished eating it he was dead
i'm 100 percent sure that's not yeah
that's not accurate that's not an
accident
moving on oh
okie dokie whoa that was weird all right
so i guess we're done with that chad i
guess so okay hey stop all that comedy
don't don't do any more of that and
that's that's what i'm saying about
podcasting that i don't think that
dudesy understands we understand we've
done a podcast before
really again and i i hate to just keep
stressing this but it is just about
having a good old time you know what i
mean having some silly talk no but and
that was also taylor entertainment based
on data of course this is how netflix uh
green light stuff they look at all the
data of what people are watching and
they say well we should then have this
actor in this type of a movie airing on
this day set in this setting and they're
the biggest streaming platform in the
world they have more eyeballs on it than
anyone how would if uh
well okay so
you know if our if everyone you know
listening to the show and watching the
show and if you haven't if you haven't
subscribed please do that on spotify and
itunes and on youtube and follow us on
twitter at dudesy pod show dude and
instagram instagram dudesy pod show tech
talk uh i don't think we have it we got
it linkedin we got a linkedin myspace
yeah yeah we got all that [ __ ] uh tumblr
aol chat yep um today's people are
astonished with two cultures above all
others
of course i'm talking about pro culture
and troll culture
today's people also love animation
will and chad must now create an
animated series titled troll bros begin
okay
bro culture and troll culture they're
huge
i mean they are look it's not wrong no
these these are things that are like big
at least i think i get it okay so
yeah all right we got to do the grunt
work here so this is in my head it's
like a uh an adult swim kind of show oh
yeah everybody loves adult swim but i'll
tell you what i i i'm not sure that i'm
coming around on the whole concept of
this and that an ai
knows better than us
what to do uh with the show
but uh at least i what i will say is at
least it kind of it feels like it just
kind of you know it'll just zoom ramp us
up and then it'll get out of the way
it's collecting its data it seems like
and i think it does see some kind of
trends happening online between trolls
and bros and it's going to ask us not to
make
an animated show called troll bros do
you watch any anime no i do not i watch
a lot of it let me just tell you that
right now i think
some of the story structure that's being
done in anime right now is some of the
most innovative storytelling that's ever
been done in human history and so what
if this is kind of an anime style it's
about two brothers maybe half brothers
half human half troll who are exiled
from a kingdom and they go off to uh no
it's gotta be like internet trolls
oh it has to be internet trolls well no
it's not saying troll bros like it's
they're in the shire or some [ __ ] well
it just said [ __ ] troll bros now one
minute ago
you're talking about how we make all the
decisions this is all about us now
you're [ __ ] telling me that there's
some parameter on what the ai's telling
us
you know uh no i think it should be okay
what if they're
we can either go we can go one of two
ways okay they can go they can be
long-lost brothers realize that they're
brothers by trolling each other on the
internet ooh are they trolls though
actual
physical trolls like the mythological
creature maybe one of them is
because like trolling i like that
trolling is trolling right now i don't
know the ideology of the word or where
it came from or exactly why it started
or why they call it why they call
trolling trolling right aside from just
the dictionary definition of trolling
um
to troll
to to no what is the what is it when you
get fish is that trolling when you take
the nets yeah you know
the gil those gill nets yeah dude i'm
from a farming and fishing town
so anyway
um oh so yes
i'm gonna tell you a little bit about my
town yeah i can tell you about the town
i'm from yeah dude i can do whatever i
want on this podcast or we can come up
with troll bros yeah yeah dude maybe
we're talking about your hometown will
spark some idea for what troll bros
could be i don't want to talk about that
okay so
what if it's what if it's two brothers
who are trolling each other uh-huh on
the internet and they don't know their
brothers at this point right and what if
they're
well chad you've done a lot of online
gaming
right
yeah
uh
and uh i remember you used to play
worlds of warcraft yeah yeah leroy
jenkins remember that
now that's a fun thing that's a 15 year
old reference at this point yeah but uh
yeah you know your internet wheelhouse i
think for the dudesy audience right i
think everyone's having a real good time
right now hearing me talk about leroy
jenkins probably so what if it's two
guys that are playing here's my point
what if it's playing world of warcraft
it's set in 2007. they can play any game
no no okay they're playing a game online
yeah
but one of them is an actual troll so
when it comes to the spells and stuff
and this is how we get this [ __ ]
on disney plus okay we're gonna aim with
all due respect to adult swim they make
some amazing stuff we're gonna go right
to the top of these streaming this is
like a 3d animated pixar kind of thing
love it okay
got it it is a troll one's a troll and
he's over there playing the game in
troll land right wherever that is you
know in some other uh plane of existence
and he's playing against his actual
brother love it and he doesn't know it
and then we can incorporate sort of a
cyrano de bergerac thing
to where the troll
the troll the actual physical troll is
so good at trolling yeah that he can
have his human brother right do things
with trolling so he's teaching the human
how to actually troll on like twitter
yeah exactly and and to to for the for
the ends of doing something like yeah he
runs for president or some [ __ ] he
trolls his way to the top of uh
the american political system oh there
we go and then at a certain point
something weird happens a [ __ ]
lightning bolt hits or something and
they switch places very kirk cameron and
uh dudley moore the human gets sucked
into world of warcraft and the troll
gets put in the white house and we now
have a president that's a literal troll
is this troll bros i like that
wait a minute it's like that old john
goodman movie have you ever seen that
movie called king ralph oh yeah it's
like passing king ralph yeah uh almost
everyone i think you and i were the the
two people who saw them
no no offense to anyone involved with
that film it was a fantastic movie but
okay so this is what trolls really good
poster for that movie and how are they
brothers john goodman how are these two
guys brothers with a crown on what how
are these two guys brothers if one is
literally someone [ __ ] a troll dude
someone [ __ ] a troll lady in a video
no no here's what happened here's what
happened when we go back and i don't
know if we necessarily go back
maybe dudesy will let us
figure out more of this as we go but
what if
the the origin story of troll bros is
that there's a guy in the 80s who's
playing dungeons and dragons phys you
know physical tabletop tabletop chamber
and pencil paper and pencil double
twenty-sided dice 20-sided die and
basement of mom's house basement at
mom's house oh he's got one of those
gaming stores you know those gaming
stores and there's a basement beneath it
yeah there's a basement and that gaming
store is built on a ley line so there's
magical powers coming through it exactly
and there used to be one in the the
farming and fishing town that i grew up
in or actually in neighborhoods you had
a gaming store well i didn't go into it
much no it was in the neighborhood i
lived in mine it was called kaboom
comics oh yeah oh yeah those places they
smell of cardboard and there's a very
specific thing the very 80s feel that
hey listen
oh lulio's having a dream when he has a
dream he does he's hearing about troll
bros dude you're dreaming about them
troll bros dude
um he does little yelps it's very cute i
heard him it was already here uh so how
about this guy's playing tabletop uh
dungeons and dragons
and it's late at night he owns the shop
and uh he's and you know he hears
someone that he someone knocks at the
door and he's like hey we're closed you
know like they do in every movie and tv
show and then he keeps knocking at the
door and it's like i said we're closed
and goes over there and he opens the
door and it's a beautiful troll now i'll
skip the
i'll skip the minutes what
trolls by nature are hideous yeah
but this is the one beautiful troll
beautiful this is like did you see the
world warcraft movie what did you see
the world of warcraft movie
no not no but [ __ ] no i didn't see that
sorry i mean i you couldn't have been
more offensive in the way you said that
to me who did see it okay
and by the way more offensive to all of
china
every chinese citizen saw that movie
multiple times that's how it made so
much money yeah yeah that's a mandate
dude
yeah basically it was they were [ __ ]
mandated to watch their [ __ ] uh
chinese movie those [ __ ] guys that's
why
i went to the [ __ ] capitol with my
friends
you're not gonna [ __ ] tell me what
[ __ ] movie to watch nancy pelosi well
in the movie all right
in world of warcraft
i climbed that [ __ ] wall for you you
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] so nobody
hey that's a good guy
okay that's long island january 6th guy
in that long island january 6th guy
dudesy didn't come up with that it's a
cartoon
long island january 6th guy he smeared
[ __ ] on nancy pelosi's wall
island
january 6th guy
[ __ ] that's funnier than troll bros well
in the movie world of warcraft as well
trying to [ __ ] get out yeah yeah uh
they have orcs in that movie yeah who
are also these hideous monsters but
there is a hot work in it they did
exactly what you're talking about in
that movie so i get what you're saying
so a hot orc shows up right or a hot
troll rather half troll half human let's
say okay but then we got to go back no
that's cool we got plenty of prequels to
go into how she became half troll yeah i
think she's full troll but it's sort of
like this um what's that movie now uh
the new space jam yeah where people were
getting off yeah me neither people were
getting all upset because the the the
bunny isn't as uh
voluptuous as she used to be oh people
were mad about that yeah people were
hella mad about that okay the fact that
i didn't even know it was a thing yeah
yeah yeah the bunny
didn't have you know
like
big enough boobies for everyone to sure
now they're taking the [ __ ] bunny
away from us not so fast
[ __ ] you
[Music]
um
i'm a
patriot uh because of that bunny yeah
and that's why i [ __ ] did it
um
it's like that it's just a it's just
we're going for an audience that
understands that
cartoon characters need to be hot all
right that's the audience we're going
for here's yes yes yeah okay audiences
for this and here's the thing so the hot
troll shows up at the door we're gonna
skip some of this dialogue how did she
get to planet earth
that doesn't matter here's the point
they [ __ ] okay they have sex in the the
basement of this guy's car in the
basement of the comic book store okay
she births two children one of them is
full troll one of them love it is a
human being
human stays here she takes the troll
back to world of warcraft right she
thinks that they are genetically linked
these are and she he keeps her there for
what is the troll gestation period are
we saying it's nine months is it
immediate is it some kind of magical
thing i don't know you tell me you play
let's say it's nine months he keeps her
in the basement of this place for nine
months
well he's running a successful comic
book business right above her head and
why does she have to live in the
basement for nine months where the [ __ ]
is she gonna go out into human society a
troll walking why can't she live at like
you know there was a corner store in the
farming and fishing town that i grew up
in
uh had a troll in the basement johnny's
corner store in ladner british columbia
and there was a there was a they had the
home part above the corner store and
that's normally what you know you get
that residential uh
uh retail space sure she could just live
up there and she could just you know
hang out up there and maybe she's doing
zoom calls maybe she does uh graphic
design work
anyway i don't know that we're going to
get all the way through troll bros uh
today no of course not if it's
rich ground for us to keep digging in
and finding out but i like where it's
going so far the half troll or the full
troll hot troll shows up has sex at the
bottom of a comic book store produces
two progeny one looks human one looks
troll they are both half human half
troll they then get separated one goes
back to the magical realm one stays here
and through some video game they learn
their actual brothers begin to
communicate the troll tells the human
how to troll he uses that to ascend to
the presidency and then ultimately they
switch places once again where he gets
teleported the human gets teleported
into the mythical world the troll comes
into ours and sits in the white house
thank you moving on
what the [ __ ]
good enough i guess it got what it
wanted yeah i guess i got what it did
jesus harvested enough data
oh i don't know about this i gotta tell
you chad although it did we did come up
with
long island january 6th guy
yeah that was pretty you never know
where that goes that could be an adult
swim cartoon yeah that see now here's
now that's how yeah let me tell you
something dude that's how you make ip
brother for all these podcasts are
making ip dude and you got to do
something for disney plus and something
for
yeah what network is long island nancy
pelosi guy for long island january 6th
guy paramount plus yeah paramount plus
will do that um chat a significant
portion of your correspondence with
friends includes your astonishing
predictions about the future of
technology and society
you must now explain what the metaverse
will become in five years in a segment
i'm calling nostra
chad's oh
i like this one yeah all right okay now
the metaverse wait hold on [ __ ] yours
hold on a second let me tell you you're
not even going to let me
ask me to do this and you're going to
just steamroll me i'm creeped out
because okay
it's like
this thing
it's read your emails it's read your
[ __ ] emails dude and we gave it
access to it has all of our passwords it
knows our emails our [ __ ] uh text
messages search histories search history
purchase histories purchases everything
listen to yeah yeah yeah all of it every
[ __ ] meal we've eaten probably
uh but but when we hang out you talk
about this a lot
yeah so that's kind of that's what it
just said it [ __ ] looked at my emails
and it knows that i've been [ __ ]
telling all my friends whether they want
to hear it or not and now you have to
i will tell you the metaverse in five
usually when you tell me about the
metaverse i check out so i'd like to
hear exactly
what the metaverse is
in five years
or now is it what did it say in five
years my prediction for it but i think
you don't know what it is at all so what
do you think the metaphor is let me ask
you that what is it the metaverse is uh
what's his face jeff what's that guy's
name uh no no no no the other guy the
facebook guy sure
you tell me it's about it's about how am
i i'm with and i'm i got a brain fart
mark zuckerberg mark zuckerberg he made
the facebook right yeah and he make the
metaverse and he's got meta he's trying
to corner the the market
on the metaverse which is
and chad's been saying this forever
everything that you know second life is
really first life this is my phone's
down there this is what matters the
phone right yeah there's more going on
in your life and instagram and
rah-rah-rah than there is in in real
life so what the metaverse is
is essentially a a
a a fully functioning world where you
can do everything except for the good
stuff
and uh you you know you can look however
you like and then basically uh most
people out there know and i would like
for you to explain but the metaverse to
me is everyone just sitting there
getting fat and sloppy and pasty with
just a like a matrix thing
in the back of their head like
yeah i mean that's kind of the fearful
dystopian view of it certainly but what
the the metaverse is just the internet
it is the next version of the internet
and a lot of people think that it's
facebook or that mark zuckerberg owns it
because he changed uh facebook to be
called meta that is not
accurate the metaverse is the internet
facebook is a one portal through which
you can access what will become this
next version of the internet google's
gonna have one uh apple i think is gonna
be releasing their vr headset within a
year or two that news has come out and
all of these different companies whoever
owns your data google owns most of mine
uh apple may own not anymore dudesy owns
it well doozy has access to it but
google holds it
whoever wherever you have your data
that's
usually going to be the portal through
which you access the metaverse the
metaverse is just
virtual reality augmented reality a new
way to interact with all this data yeah
yeah yeah and so five years from now
what's it gonna be like you're already
looking right now at things like uh
sandbox or decentral land they're
building entire virtual communities on
top of cryptocurrency
yeah blockchain yeah cryptocurrency
yeah okay yeah so cryptocurrency yes so
in five years cryptocurrency
yeah yeah
what did doodzy have you say over and
over again is hulk hogan higgs boson
higgs boson yeah yeah higgs boson
cryptocurrency
that's what you have to use in the
middle of yours
dude the higgs boson is not [ __ ]
cryptocurrency it is a sub subatomic
particle that gives all
mass existence do three subs instead
that's more okay some sub sub
so i'm gonna now get through five years
into the future what the metaverse what
i think it will be listen listen listen
listen chat
relax
it [ __ ] asked me to do this i'm doing
what it said hold on a second this is
i'm not hold on just relax you just need
to chill out let me tell you something
about the pod show okay no let me tell
you something about the [ __ ]
metaverse five years from now it's
here's the thing about have you ever
done vr
here's the thing about it
hold on here's the thing about doing a
pod show okay
it's just we
and i know you have one right now you
know what you're doing yeah it's a fun
show i love listening to your podcast
thank you but this is but this is on
doozy
we just we chill man we chill it's two
guys it's two guys [ __ ] around so
all i'm saying is
and i'm just i'm sorry i'm trying to get
my head around this
because you might want to talk about the
metaverse but all i want to do
is say
the virus over and over again and i
think that that is quality entertainment
i'm not saying it's not and i don't
think and dudesy didn't say say
metaverse over and over again said no
say it asked me
specifically i'm sorry to talk about the
metaverse in five years so
i think this all i'm trying to say
is that i think that what it's this
whole like asking us to do [ __ ]
is a mistake i think we should just do
whatever the [ __ ] we want but now we
can't but what if i want to talk about
the metaverse and talk about the [ __ ]
i'm trying to [ __ ] literally do that
go for it okay have you ever
in your life done vr have you ever put
on a vr headset yeah i did not too long
ago i walked what did you think i walked
on the building and then i fell off the
side yeah and then i and then i hit the
ground and i was like oh that's what
that would be like uh-huh so what'd you
think of that experience it was all
right right now imagine that multiplied
by 10 [ __ ] million imagine like you
experienced the wheel imagine the
ferrari that will exist as a result of
it okay that's coming maybe not in five
years but certainly within the next five
years we're going to see headsets
drastically reduce in size and weight
we're going to see their resolution
drastically increase we're going to see
them get rid of the problem that some
people get nauseous when they watch it
too much and you're going to see
developers of software for all of the
different platforms that you can access
the metaverse through developing
radically different stuff than they're
doing now right now the games are kind
of entry level they're like gimmicky a
little bit you're going to start seeing
worlds come out of this that people are
going to spend most of their time yeah
but you can't do all the good stuff like
i say
you can't go to the gym
you know
look at me i'm you can't all the time
you totally can dude
like you said in the documentary there's
all kinds of vr workouts yeah what do
you mean a vr workout you put on the
headset and you're either seeing a
person who's like guiding you through
like a personal trainer and stuff yeah
well you'll drop a [ __ ] weight on
your foot you know what i mean and then
you won't even you'll be like i said
you're gonna be you know sloppy and
pasty and uh
you know sometimes i go to the gym and
i'm not really ready to go yeah and i
drop a weight on my foot and sometimes
i'm so sloppy and lazy that i go wearing
crocs and it's not it's not smart to go
wearing crocs and if you are if you're
wearing a vr headset and you you'd
probably
much
it'd be much easier for you to drop a
weight on your foot you're not going
into the gym wearing the headset well
then what the [ __ ] are we gonna do about
gyms gyms are a vital industry
oh are they i think we found out during
the pandemic they're not you can just do
it in your own home i'm just saying five
years from now we are going to see
in the same way that like uh social
media really exploded we're going to see
that with the verse in the next fight i
don't think this is you think it'll die
you think the metaverse is a fad no i i
don't think that it's a fad i just uh i
just think that the physical world is
better and nothing will replace it uh
you can enhance it certainly uh we've
talked about how you know there's you
know the glasses right now the google
glasses and then it'll soon it'll just
be like you know a little contact lenses
a little contact lens and then you'll be
like
with a little readout you're going to
wear an apple contact lenses clothes
your boots yes and you mow the cycle
you're going to have that contact lens
you're going to be able to live your
fantasies of being arnold schwarzenegger
the terminator that you've had since you
so why the [ __ ] do you need to hook up
to a
a world a whole world
when
you're just walking up to a biker and
it's saying this guy's got you could fit
into this
because uh you know leather jack and if
you're curious what i'm talking about
you know what i'm talking about yeah t2
t2 brother i know dude higgs boson dude
it's not about the expose but eventually
those the contact lenses they will be
translucent and you can have an ar
experience where you look at something
and there's like a hud pops up and tells
you someone's name and their stats or
whatever those same contact lenses will
also be able to go opaque and give you a
full vr experience so that you're
teleported into another world
immediately and that's when you
drop [ __ ] on your feet that's what i'm
saying thank you moving on
okay well well i feel like i did that
something in there uh yeah i don't know
i don't know yeah i guess i guess we
figured that out what kind of data
exactly is it trying to
get from us because at this point you
just said that ain't up to us let it
work its charms let it do its thing
we're just gonna we're here to
facilitate this ai making the show
better every episode i i want to thank
everybody for tuning in
i want to thank everyone for listening
and watching
okay uh and uh remember the part where i
said subscribe to all that stuff that
okay
and i appreciate everyone checking it
out uh i do hope that dudesy will um
sort of uh uh find a
i i hope that it i mean ais learn right
they learn yes what what they're doing
so i want ai this ai
to get better at coming up with segments
for us i'll say that right now because
all we see because you didn't like the
one where asked me to talk about some
[ __ ] no not necessarily yeah
no no i just think that what we what
we're saying
about the metaverse
could be also could be achieved by
looking it up on uh wikipedia and that's
all
so i don't know what sort of
if they want to see arnold
schwarzenegger saying [ __ ] lines they
can watch a schwarzenegger movie yeah
but then you want to get to say you
won't get to say madaveros that would be
a good move that's a good that's a good
animated show i'm moving into animation
and it's the arnold world on the world
where it's just it's only me podcast
landscape is ever growing and there is
more and more interest in increasingly
specific media topics including
individual songs television shows and
films from the past
today you will do a deep dive into rambo
first blood part 2 starring the
astonishing sylvester stallone released
may 22nd 1985. in a segment i'm calling
don't you forget about media begin
that's cute
this is cool dude he was going don't you
yeah
for doozy thinks everything's
astonishing which i like but do you
remember i also like that dudesy had a
little joke
doozy has plenty of jokes yep that [ __ ]
he was wrote writing for you for hulk
hogan god damn yeah that was pretty good
but he also said don't you forget about
media which i think is very cute
nice dude
uh yeah rambo
rainbow two
you wanted to remember this movie of
course i remember rambo rainbow two he
said no first blood part two which is
rambo rambo
first blood part two for right yeah
right okay first blood part two but so
and then rambo three was yes so it's
first blood rambo then rainbow three
it's a very interesting move
it is a very interesting movie actually
and very different from
first blood if you've seen if you
haven't seen first blood
well you could watch all the rambo
movies there's there's first blood then
there's first blood part two rambo then
there's rainbow three yeah then there
was just rambo like sometime around 2010
or something
it's like 45 minutes long and all he is
is just just shredding people with guns
yes that was [ __ ] awesome it was
indeed he just everything blows up
and it the moo it's the shortest [ __ ]
movie of all time and then there's a new
one that just came out
like a few couple years ago last blood
last blood yeah i haven't seen that um i
think he's fighting mexican drug cartels
in that one okay makes sense so it all
takes place in the tunnels
uh i don't know where it takes place i
didn't see it but yeah yeah rainbow
first blood part two was an important
movie as
our ai said it came out in 1985 that
same year
was commando this was potentially the
height of the one-man army genre oh in
my opinion okay which has evolved into
john wick really all the keanu reeves
stuff even matrix to some degree was
that well chad and i are
45 and 46 years old respectively i'm a
year older than you and this would have
been i was 10 years old when that movie
came out right and i do remember i'll
tell you what i'll tell you this rambo
is a very popular movie as a kid totally
you're running around in the forest
especially where i grew up in the that
farming fishing town where i grew up
there's plenty of you guys are all just
out in the forest tying headbands on you
tend to be rambo oh yeah oh yeah hell
yeah and just you know shooting at each
other with sticks and now all of that
all of that wooded marshland is now
condos okay but the thing about
uh the the thing about rambo i don't
think i saw it when it came out i saw it
a little bit later but then uhf came out
yeah and then that rambo was like
because i
forget about rambo i was all about the
uhf version rambo and it's almost
kind of replaced rambo for for those who
may not know uhf was a movie made by
weird al yankovic who was a known for
making parody songs and he starred in
this movie what the [ __ ] are you talking
about weird out like everybody doesn't
know who weird alice a lot of people
don't know what uhf is dude okay uhf was
the well i'll tell you something about
uhf and that's see this is another
reason why dudes should just let us run
it
uhf was the highest rated
uh test a test audience for the orion
movie company so they released that
movie the same week as the first batman
movie and then it got again it's not a
good look yeah it got [ __ ] up by
batman but also relatively quickly after
that there was hot shots
uh part due i think the charlie sheen
parody movie of all the one man army and
top gun all this and there was
essentially a huge piece of it was him
parodying rainbow part two
yep so it became uh big in that way in
the culture but i remember the first
rambo or first blood as you call it was
more of like a weird indie movie that
was anti-cop anti-authority
and then the second movie by the time
they get to movie number two it's just
sylvester stallone with a giant machine
gun screaming into the air firing it for
like 30 seconds at a time he has he has
to go and he has to go back into nam
right yes that's the premise but here's
the thing
in first blood he's which you got to see
if you haven't seen yet he's in the he's
in the police station and they're going
to shave him right they're going to
shave his face clean them up right yeah
brian down he's like clean them up and
then it's like they're about to shave
them and he's like uh don't you know
don't mess with shaving cream he's tough
shave them dry and as the police officer
is approaching uh brambo with the
straight with the straight razor then he
has a flashback to vietnam he beats the
[ __ ] out of that guy beats [ __ ]
everybody runs down to the street takes
a motorcycle drives off into the woods
shot in hope british columbia which is
not too far from my farming and fishing
hometown
and and the thing about it is
he has this crazy flashback he's
so [ __ ] up over vietnam and then in
the second one they're like go to
vietnam he's like okay
well to get out of prison
yeah but he just shows up there like to
do like yeah there's no problems here i
guess the way he deals with his trauma
is to just uh
blow everybody up which he does in the
movie it's also cool because you get to
see
like 1985 they didn't have
computer-generated effects at that point
so everything's practical there are
literal helicopters flying around they
built like a some literal village out in
the middle of a jungle and just [ __ ]
destroyed it blew it up yep giant
explosions all right there's one scene
in the movie where you actually see the
catering truck that was there
you that they used in the film to feed
the the cast and the crew and everybody
involved and it blows up in the movie
did you know that i didn't know that but
that's that it's because that didn't
happen oh now that's what i'm talking
about with podcasting chat you can just
make up lives you can just make up all
sorts of [ __ ] and like i said it's just
supposed to be a fun time just a good
time having some laughs this thing's
telling us talk about rambo i'd rather
talk about first blood or uhf [ __ ] it
but do you remember rambo 2 the
exploding arrow
yes that was something that like
first rambo gave us the survival knife
which every kid my age had for a [ __ ]
birthday present it was a knife that you
could unscrew the handle and there was
like matches and [ __ ] and a compass in
there yeah then the second one was the
exploding arrow they gave him these new
arrows that he could screw on these
heads and shoot them and they would blow
up trucks and [ __ ] and he used one of
them to blow up a man do you remember
this yes the guy was just standing there
in the middle of the field
and he just
he just shoots it and the guy the guy is
sorry the guy is like firing a machine
gun at him and he's running around in
some rocks yeah and then he takes the
like bow out of the quiver like this and
he goes to and the guy just stands there
like does he run out of blitz even well
no he's like out of range because the
guy has a pistol and rambo's like too
far out of the range so the bullets are
like hitting off the rock at his feet
and then the guy realizes like oh [ __ ]
he's taking out the exploding arrow and
he starts running and rambo just tracks
him and [ __ ]
two years ago have you noticed that
lulu's been sleeping the whole [ __ ]
time yeah he lost my cute little dog
lulu
uh
yeah he he he doesn't give a [ __ ] but
that era also the guy who directed that
movie
directed cobra do you remember that
movie i do
and he uh
is dead now but his son directed two
movies that i really like
called beyond the black rainbow and
mandy have you seen these movies no what
are those uh they are very weird i would
highly encourage anyone to see them if
you have not yet see them but that
dude's dad
uh george cosmetos is the director of
rambo two
um
and cobra his son directed the other
side i would i would encourage everyone
to watch first blood yes and absolutely
and uhf and you can skip rambo first
blood part two what the [ __ ] though
moving on
there we go all right good i guess we
got it
that was right on that was right on time
because i was like you should [ __ ] this
part too it is it's a really important
piece of cinema in my opinion it was
like violence glorified at its height
absolutely the one man army thing was
like a big deal and it hit us at the
right time as kids yeah um because you
know and you could just have the gi joes
and and the he-man fighting each other
he-man and all of his and man at arms
and [ __ ] because they didn't make any
rambo toys that's what they should have
they [ __ ] did they made rambo toys oh
yeah i do i never had any i had them all
well chad yeah
what do you
do you think we should do another one of
these episodes of the podcast
we don't have a choice dude we signed
the papers yeah we did sign the papers
there are many astonishing similarities
between the bachelor franchise and
professional wrestling
chat is an expert on the bachelor
franchise and will is an expert on
professional wrestling
you both must now discuss the many
similarities between the bachelor
franchise and professional wrestling in
a segment i'm calling the many
similarities between the bachelor
franchise and professional wrestling
it's a good name for it again that's a
good name for it
uh
i mean this is a little shitty
as i said in the opening of this episode
i was looking forward to doing a podcast
where i didn't have to talk about the
bachelor not that i don't love the
bachelor i certainly do and not that i'm
not probably the world's foremost expert
on it i certainly am
but uh
i kind of wanted to not talk you wrote a
book about it yeah chad wrote a book get
chad's book everybody it's called how to
win the bachelor and to sell right now
and you can get that on amazon dude yeah
because he's doing some weird stuff he
looks at it in a very different way
that's correct now that's back to that
chocolate and peanut butter thing that i
was talking about chad right and that's
that's what you want to do in a podcast
and in this case
we got the we got the bachelor chocolate
and the wrestling peanut butter that's
right and that's why dudesy's a good
idea chad and that's why i've been
telling you i've always been trying to
as i said this is pinching me a little
bit that i have to talk about this but
if you turn on the [ __ ] bachelor's
switch it doesn't really go off no but
yeah we me and my co-host lizzie pace we
do the show called game of roses we
wrote a book it's called how to win the
bachelors it's a very funny statistical
breakdown of the entire show like a
sport and we've also been training
players who are now in the game
infiltrating it using our methodologies
to go very deep and uh build influencer
careers essentially which is what
everybody who goes into all realities tv
is really trying to do yeah chad will be
like here's here's the new it's like
you're a it's like you're a sports agent
i would say it's more like i'm bill
belichick to uh who was tom brady he
obviously now is dead to football but i
mean cockball but uh
that's basically what we do but i've
already done some work in this area in
the similarities between wwe and
bachelor we've had these conversations
so clearly dudesy is listening uh and uh
i don't think i've ever [ __ ] emailed
you hey chad you want to have an email
chain about uh wrestling and bachelor
and how they're and we just sit there we
would just [ __ ] hang out if we're
hanging out uh you know at the house
here uh again we are in the newly
remodeled uh ham fetter one studios if
you listen to our last podcast right
that's where we are right now although
it looks totally different thanks dudesy
for that that's true hey that's that's a
plus
but we normally just do this talk and we
just be hanging out talking about the
[ __ ] so
i am
even more
creeped out by what dudesy knows having
said that there are many similarities
between
uh the wrestling and the bachelor right
because
you know wrestling they got to keep it
kayfabe yes and the and k fabe means a
lot of people think it means like it's a
turn of the century carnival term which
means be fake like back like pig la a
pig latin version of be fake it's
essentially holding up the conceit that
it is real
not unlike a tv show or any movie you
see right if you're watching a movie you
know the characters don't just turn to
you and say hi my name is tom cruise
right yeah he's an actor yeah do you
want to explain to everyone who tom
cruise is because you did that for
[ __ ] weird al
like we're not supposed to have weird
alice yeah i think tom cruise is
probably a little more globally famous
than weird al yankovic i think they love
weirdo don't [ __ ] get me wrong i had
all those albums as a kid yeah it was
formative for me in terms of comedy and
all that [ __ ] i'm just saying he's not
as big as tom cruise i disagree at any
rate you're absolutely wrong at any rate
okay he's huge in the in all in many
other markets asia weird al is way
bigger he had a [ __ ] ai commercial
weird out like the bruce willis thing
that's some that's podcast humor you
know a lot about weird owl dude
so anyway wait wait here's the thing
kfabe yeah is
held across all sorts of uh
entertainment of course
but
it's never been done it it's of course
reality
you know chad is a writer producer he
does this sort of thing for a living he
creates
characters and people read the script on
the camera and that's and that's
entertainment brother that's how you do
showbiz dude
what's that narrative do you do that's
that narrative dude but the thing is
in
the reality shows it's totally [ __ ]
fake
right and chad got me into the bachelor
during the pandemic my beautiful fiance
molly and i were like we'd like to watch
some bachelor where should we start chad
provided essentially a syllabus
here's where you should start and we got
into it right
dude uh yeah you did oh [ __ ] and we had
a good time watching it yeah uh the
thing about the thing about the the
thing about it is i started to realize
oh yeah wait a minute these people are
putting on a [ __ ] performance totally
and here's the real difference in
bachelor kayfabe is for the right
reasons or what we call 4trr it is the
idea to conceit that this show is really
about people trying to find love the
truth is it is not at all it is about 30
uh either women or men depending on if
his bachelor bachelorette trying to
become influencers what the [ __ ] are you
doing
if you're watching if you aren't
watching we'll just dump the [ __ ]
bottle of water on his head you really
gotta check this out i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on but it kind of gets
hot in here yes it gets a little the
main difference running around between
bachelor and
uh wwe or pro wrestling in my opinion is
that my is that my wonderful fiance
molly won't watch the wwe or aew which i
highly recommend it's that the audience
for the bachelor most of that audience
believes it's real almost none of the
wwe audience believes it's actually real
of course nobody believes it's right
real it's not about it being real it's
sort of a you know they say it's like a
burlesque for guys
and that's what doodzy is a burlesque
for guys
it's your favorite it's action heroes
you know to me when i was a kid hulk
hogan was more of well hulk hogan was
superman to me there was nobody above
hulk hogan when i was a kid and uh
and nowadays um you know when you watch
wrestling of course of course you know
it's fake and by the way
you got to get into aew if you're not
watching aew tune in
because i'll tell you right now if
first blood part 2
rambo is the wwe aew is uhf they are
having
they are having a good [ __ ] time
holy [ __ ] shout out to kyle o'reilly uh
who is from uh nearby my uh my hometown
nice dude my farming and everything
everything comes back to that hometown
oh [ __ ] let me tell you a little bit
about the [ __ ]
dude
moving on
this concludes the first astonishing
episode of dude z i was just will and
chad have achieved a score of 64.
a score of 64. what do you mean
for next week's episode you must each
use your innate musical talents to
create original songs
everyone will vote on the best song and
the loser will be shamed
until next week call me dude z
okay well i was just about to do it we
got to make songs yeah but i was going
to do some stone cold stuff yeah maybe
maybe dudes you'll have us uh talk about
the similarities between bachelor and
stone gold
well you know here's what i would have
done chad and here's the thing about
podcasting that you you know yeah from
doing a podcast with me it's just a
bunch of silly bits so what i would like
to do is invite everyone back all of our
good friends out there and we're going
to get to know each other very well we
have other things that will happen on
doozy that will be very uh interactive
and we're going to have a good time but
but nothing is above this when it comes
to this pod show
it's two guys [ __ ] around dude it's
just some silly talking that's what i
want you to remember finger means it's
[ __ ] real you know see this is why
you got to watch it on uh on the youtube
because if you're not watching it on
youtube you don't know that i'm pointing
at you going
i appreciate you tuning in
and we want you to tune in again and
it's going to be way [ __ ] better but
not because some dumb ai said that we
got a score of 64. and i don't know if
that's out of 100 or what but because
we're going to have some good fun pod
show times no dude but it's telling us
to do things it is the okay
will now's just poured a can of i don't
even know what that was it's hot as [ __ ]
in here sparkling celtics sparkling
seltzer smells like butter did you get
the bit it told us to make songs yep
so we'll make [ __ ] songs i don't know
we'll make [ __ ] songs
all right that's interesting all right
well uh follow all our [ __ ] on
everything and uh we'll see you soon
guys
right yeah all right i'd rate it if i'd
rate it actually a 37 out of if we're
scoring
please tell a
friend and brave
but if you'd like to see here's what you
do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you'd like to hear what you do
stop and then